how's it going out there citizens of the
reject Nation it is I John here again
for another solo movie reaction it's
been a little while thank you for
joining me if you're joining me leave a
like on the video first and foremost
because uh we are about to check out a
comedy classic from what I understand I
missed a big swath of Jim Carrey movies
back in the day we weren't a Jim Carrey
house weren't really an Adam Sandler
house got a lot of blind spots in that
part of my viewing history I know a
couple things about this movie I've
obviously seen little images and certain
little gross out gags but for the most
part I really don't know what I'm
getting into other than a fairly
Brothers comedy right with Jim Carrey
and Jeff Daniels I'm excited this is
gonna be a long time coming and I hope I
see what you see all you nostalgic
people out there who grew up on this I
am excited to be here today and if you
want to join me for the full length
reaction to this movie if you want to
get every moment that gets snipped out
of these highlights come on over to
patreon.com the real reject sync up with
your own copy and and join me for Dumb
and Dumber and uh yeah if you want to
support the channel you can also check
out our shopzeroedition.com store we got
some nice merch over there Greg just put
out a new shirt a who influences the
influencers shirt it's a sweet idea I
wish I came up with it anyway I think
that's all the housekeeping for right
now I'm ready for anything and I'm ready
to get loose and silly and you know
Channel my inner Jim Carrey so without
further Ado let's jump into this people
oh
Hope Street
shouts out to
meet Thomas
if you know you know
could you tell me how to get to the
medical school I'm supposed to be doing
a lecture in about 20 minutes and my
driver's a bit lost you go straight
ahead you make the left over the bridge
New Jersey Austria Austria
well then good day mate ah you knew it
was coming let's put another shrimp on
the ball Bay
let's not
ship it into oh
let's get a little bit of prop comedy
right there with the window
[Laughter]
what were you gonna do she got in
you and me both
this this song is just it forces you to
jiggle
yeah
what year was this made that that title
card looked very very quintessential 90s
animation
let's write the dog van mutt cuts
oh God
it's making me hungry oh sir I didn't
want to send them to a performance on an
empty stomach sir
yes sir
oh God this is not gonna this is not
gonna go well right they gotta show some
kind of dog show I'm just counting down
the seconds to the first poop gag
produced by
[Music]
oh
yeah
good physical comedy of course but also
some nice little prop comedic moments so
where are you headed
Aspen California
name's Christmas Lloyd Christmas that's
right where my Christmas socks for this
occasion my friend Harry and I are
saving up our money to open our own pet
store
that's nice
I got worms that's what we're gonna call
it I got worms we're gonna specialize in
selling worm farms you know like ant
farms
I got worms the tents about the flight
something like that
there's really nothing to worry about
Mary statistically they say you're more
likely to get killed on the way to the
airport
trapped under a gas truck that's the
worst I have this cousin oh
it's interesting changing the exposure
when the explosion is going off this
feels like a comic strip
in real life that probably would have
totaled that car that van I beat them
and I clipped them myself
ugh you know what second thought you
might just want to run a comb through
him
you know
they're hip now shine a black light on
him they're they're punk rock how about
a hug
you don't have to do that
I hate goodbyes
uh boys
she's gonna leave the briefcase near the
escalator
you make the pickup character actors
this is a beautiful little symphony of
expressions from her as well oh no
case
they're in there she left it let's go
it's
a great little slide there you can't go
in there whoa it's okay
I'm a limo driver
[Laughter]
God today you'd be like tackled and
tased whoa oh no excellent
who the hell you figure this guy's
working for anyway
there's hell better find out
[Music]
the Elsa
I'll live
I love that trope
it just take five or six of these
well I lost my job too man
you are one pathetic loser
no offense
no none taken
[Laughter]
I drove to the airport
Sparks flew motions were in high
she actually talked to me man
what's in it
I would have to be a low-life to go
rooting around in somebody else's
private property is it locked yeah
really well of course
classic swimsuit poster well one of them
nice fisheye lens there did you pay the
gas bill
[Laughter]
well he's got to come home sometime oh
maybe we should trash the place send
them a little message do not harm the
bird
no uh I thought I'd throw a puddy cat
crazy man
that's hard that's hard you guys you
guys need to tell me which like that's
gonna happen
ugh
dude could you do me a favor and watch
my stuff here while I go break a dollar
thanks
ugh senior citizens although slow and
dangerous behind the wheel can still
serve a purpose
she's gonna take all that beer right
yep
by a sweet
surprised cart a rascal or a rascal
it happened
his head fell off oh
of course
yeah it was pretty old
we got no food we got no jobs our Pet's
heads are falling off
we gotta get out of this town yeah and
go where where are we gonna go I'm
talking about a little place called
Lloyd the French are [ __ ] wait a
minute
that's been Colorado you just want to go
to Aspen and find
fine
I don't know about you but I am getting
sick and tired of running from creditors
I'm sick and tired of having to eat my
way through life oh sick and tired of
being sick and tired being a nobody but
most of all
sick and tired of having nobody
asked but it is
better not be full
wow you you guys that's how they get you
thought I'd get it so it gets you to be
genuine in the silliness
oh good shot with the goose or the duck
whatever that is the duck I saw some
stuff to Billy and 4C the blind kid
yeah
two baseball cards a sack of marbles
Petey
you sold my dead bird to a blind kid
did you at least tape his head on Petey
didn't even
don't tell me there's a cutaway ugh
[Music]
Freddy bird yes
oh buddy
oh how the hell do they know that I got
gas
he froze
this really lives up to its title excuse
me flow
[Laughter]
yes my sword is flat it doesn't have any
bubbles
ugh
[Music]
happy now
feels good to mingle with these
laid-back country folks don't it hair
I like it a lot
[Laughter]
here's where that came from that's like
seared into my memory
you spilled the salt that's what's the
matter oh bad luck forever
toss some salt over your right shoulder
ugh
oh
too little too late Harry
yes
what that no yes no well no I I crossed
my mind
[Music]
it's very gross
still want it
ah you go ahead
ugh like I even I wouldn't need that
after that if it was me and my spit
talk my friend Harry and I would
like to buy you guys a
Brown of beers making four Boilermakers
whatever you want sir oh Jesus what's he
gonna do
tea bag the Boilermakers
the best and the fellows offered to pick
up our check
ugh I mean why did you come up with a
scam like that I saw it in a movie Once
in the movie they catch up to him half
mile down the road and slit his throat
it was a good one it was a good one
sounds like
[Music]
go back
when is somebody gonna drink one of
those
going to happen
no it's a cardigan but thanks for
noticing
laughs
every every
few bits I would just want to say stupid
and I know that's the point so it was
well done
you fellas been doing a bit of boozing
have you sucking back on Grandpa's old
cough medicine no no yeah but what's
that
ugh tell the truth
the truth will set you free come on give
me that boss you little pumpkin pie
haircutted Freak come on ugh and then
he's gonna taste it and he's gonna enjoy
it Lloyd's got hoppy pee
dude keep your mouth shut if you knew it
was good for you buddy
ah yeah
that's someone's cure the gulp the gulp
attack sir
get the hell out of here
oh poor guy doesn't make sense I left
the money exactly where they instructed
me to
um we should have called the authorities
the minute we knew that Bobby was
kidnapped and Helen we've been through
this already well done if the press or
the authorities get wind of this the
kidnappers May panic
I mean you never know what they might do
to them then you're involved I don't
trust you or or at very least you're
probably a dick of some kind
oh geez
[Laughter]
set that one dub free thank you
oh love so he said do you love me and
she says no but that's a real nice ski
mask
kinky
oh Jesus no
[Laughter]
and that's a good example of leaving it
to the audience's imagination you know
see the reaction and the light of the
flame
[Music]
here we go that's right man look out
look Chris was coming as
up wow
speed bag in the sack ow ah
[Laughter]
yeah
where are we well well
[Music]
I've seen people do that
oh
[Music]
come on Lloyd
yep
he's so dreamy
this is the editing of this sequence is
very funny
I wonder if she was prepared for this
nice nice transition
no one should ever let you drive like
Christmas you're not stacked Harry ready
banging you right now wowie you'd
probably like it too you big homo shut
up
no don't tell me to shut up woman oh no
guys there's nothing wrong with giving
to your desires
what happened Harry some little Philly
break your heart no it was a girl no it
was a girl
of course felcher from Cranston did you
know her oh yeah I thought we're gonna
be together forever
about a week later another blue she
sends me a John Deere letter John dear
letter
because I think she was seeing another
guy oh
never did find out who
oh Lloyd say it ain't so
oh Lloyd
it's messed up dude that's your that's
your Rider die yeah the boys are pulled
up in a little love nest for the night
this poor guy
guy rehearsing I knew it
I knew it
knew I didn't trust you
get off the phone yeah
yeah get off the top
that was hard Jokers have got a lot of
money and it belongs to me of course I
want to know who they are and what
they're doing with it oh it's dead what
the family's dead what the houses put to
the ground I bet you 20 bucks I can get
you gambling before the end of the day
no way oh I'll give you a three to one
odds nope five to one nope ten to one
[Laughter]
you'll find it don't worry you'll find
it are you guys going to Davenport my
car died and I'm late for a luncheon
luncheon good cover we usually don't
pick up hitchhikers but I'm gonna go
with my instinct on this one
satellite partner
oh
you guys enough
yes
this is a very physical movie watching I
can't hear the most annoying sound in
the world oh Jesus no
[Music]
hope stopped acting like a couple of
them doesn't go at the same time huh
dude he's the perfect third wheel for
their group balances him out he's the mo
it's more tingly than hot yeah
[Music]
Harry and Lloyd would not survive a hot
ones challenge
[Music]
[Laughter]
isn't he pulls like vinegary
I'm just sitting down to a nice meal
with our boys oh how nice for you don't
forget that your bread plate is on the
left they ain't gonna be running around
nowhere after I dump a little rat poison
in their Shirley Temple oh God this is
not gonna go well this is there's some
Immaculate stupidity in this video oh no
what if my man's likes hot food oh no no
the briefcase isn't even ours how's your
burger oh my God come on guys
I'm talking about being in the wrong
place at the wrong time
yeah dig in
oh my God oh Jesus no
no
no no no no no no no
what is are you okay man it was just a
gloof
that's right ugh the ulcer of course
[Music]
they're good
huh
oh no
oh
[Music]
oh wow
it's kind of that's kind of dark it's
pretty dark
check please
of course
they were seen headed west on I-80
towards Colorado they're driving an 84
sheepdog
S I like that you can still tell what
year the car is
Colorado
oh we just got back from there it was
nice it was lovely I didn't get to go to
Aspen Colorado
but uh I recommend to visit certainly
um excuse me but you uh you're spraying
everywhere
it's a it's a metaphor it's a metaphor
ugh
for manly love here
oh no
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
love let's do this let's do some manly
love yes
[Music]
oh no
no
oh
[Music]
no he's gonna use that on you and you
wouldn't expect where that's a lot of
luggage for a little vacation oh moving
to Aspen that's my astrologer told me
that I really should stay away from
accident prone guy so you know well you
know I
no yeah
thank you oh goodness heading up to
Aspen myself maybe we could you know
meet up
look why don't you just tell it to me I
got a really good memory well the
number's
555.905. wait a minute that's my old
number oh no weird how your mind just
goes blank for God's sakes just give me
the damn number oh no okay you gonna get
pushy forget about it yeah
damn Harry you you blew it dude that was
a good thing going I'll show you a happy
place
here's your happy place oh my damn
that's that's more than I was expecting
bye bye William Frawley
oh good
yeah
whoa
oh
sea bass
what do you say we changed seats I've
been driving for nine straight hours why
should I do you any favors I'll let you
kiss me
[Laughter]
let go of the gay Panic my boys embrace
your best lives
no dude you have one shop
ah never let Lloyd behind the wheel of a
move of anything
with a wheel
let's take a good five hours
expected the Rocky Mountains to be a
little rockier than this
uh
five John Denver's full of [ __ ] man
[Laughter]
John Denver holy human Harry
can make a mistake
a way to undermine a shot and hit a one
gag you you drove almost a sixth of the
way across the country in the wrong
direction we're in whole
we're just gonna have to dig ourselves
out
yeah unfortunately I'm walking home
pardon me Mr Perfect
I guess I forgot that you never ever
make a mistake
should you walk in the same direction
the car is facing aren't you gonna walk
further away from home
the van I keep calling it a car it's a
van
the truck
some kid back in town traded the van for
it straight up I can get 70 miles to the
gallon on this hog
s and what a hug it I think you couldn't
possibly be any Dumber you go and do
something like this I'm totally riding
this
I was very curious as to what I was
gonna think about this movie but I'm I'm
quite enjoying myself
it's stupid in in a knowing way and and
that's most of the the key
board
oh goodness gracious no
no no no no
chain those tires or something
no
it's nice to be back
I was wishing I had some more time to
spend exploring Colorado this is perfect
awesome
oh
we're there
they do not look comfortable at all why
don't we get busy and deliver the
briefcase to Mary she'll invite us right
in for tea and strumpets the
planes trumpets my favorite what's her
last name I'll look it up maybe it's on
the briefcase look in the oh yeah
Samsonite oh geez I can't feel my
fingers anymore I lied look they're numb
maybe you should wear these extra gloves
this was the rehearsal damage starting
to get sweaty oh geez
you've had this pair of extra gloves
this whole time yeah
we're in the Rockies
calm down right now I'm gonna kill you
Harry you got that crazy look in your
eyes
shouts out to Andrew Gordon
he quoted that at me a few times while
we were in Colorado
but I should have done
right into that pod no no no
[Music]
no no we bore all three bucks just a
small loan from the briefcase and we
find ourselves some reasonable logic
it's a good plan whatever we bore we pay
back whatever you borrow
my Canadian friend of course princess
Charles
together
oh
[Music]
yet those ious boy oh International
preservation Society tomorrow night
you ready for the ball
how dare you
Jesus
ugh
damn it
that was good this is pretty convincing
[Music]
these gentlemen are gross Ah that's the
one that's the one boy look at that drip
look at that creamsicle ass drip
this is a 500 plate dinner oh 500 oh
okay but it's down for four in case we
want seconds
ugh
[Music]
ugh that we're able to bring Mr Swanson
forward to introduce us to the 24th
everybody Carl look at them owls come
snowy owls Hedwig these wonderful
creatures will flourish once more no
thank you again and enjoy yourself no no
no
some Terrible's gonna happen to those
owls
first time I set eyes on Mary Swanson I
just got that old-fashioned romantic
feeling
where I'd do anything to boner ugh
that's a special feeling Lloyd sure it
is yeah that's love
why don't you go over and introduce
yourself and that way you can build me
up so I won't have to brag about myself
later tell her I'm rich
a plus plan well I used to have a
parakeet but now my main area of
expertise is canines dogs to the
layperson to the labor of course thank
you we successfully made it a bulldog
with a shih tzu yeah we we called it a
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's not as funny as he thinks but it's
kind of funny
doing tomorrow I believe
Harry is looking
slopes with
I think she never gets a chance to get
out but you know the thing part sure
what time
hey I got your date with her tomorrow
thank you you have just earned yourself
a seat at the head table pal we already
got the taxes
oh yep yep yep yep
you know this is coming Pete
boy this party really died
that's just it
these guys aren't just anybody yes
they're good Merry Christmas and this is
Merry Christmas
ugh oh I should have put that together
once you get to Nora you'll find out
that she's not your type
did you ever say that again
she is the love of my life blood in my
veins we belong together until the
mountains fall into the sea till the
heavens collide
or until I get sick of her and need to
move on oh no never
oh no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no no no no no no
you're a little early uh we don't know
I don't know five minutes I'm meeting
someone here mind if I wait at the bar
there's been some family problems but I
don't want to bore you with those oh
look Frost
oh look oh geez of course of course
I thought maybe it was fast
she's running late huh
hello oh hey
interesting
it'll only hurt for a moment come on
ready
that's interesting that wasn't as
horrible as I thought it would be but it
was still pretty painful
[Music]
oh this is probably like the most she's
actually been
you know
at ease this this whole time oh I spoke
too soon oh Christ Church Mary swans she
comes in here all the time
she has dinner her family has the big
place up on Alpine Drive Alpine Drive
big place there's only one so you'll
pick me up tonight at 7 45.
bye oh what's gonna happen here
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
yep
looks like you got your night planned so
I'm just gonna head out catch a flick
okay
down in the morning
foreign
will you join me in a good luck toast
before you head out that's your thing
whatever you think will help your
chances you know what I like Harry
because you're a regular guy yep
ugh oh gee no no no no no no no no
um
oh oh
goodness what is this going to become hi
hi hi make yourself at home okay I'm
almost ready one minute okay okay sounds
good
uh oh I'm surprised it took this long
oh yeah
oh no no
we'll be back in a minute with the
heartbreaking story of the blind Rhode
Island boy who was duped into buying a
dead parakeet ugh
hi hi I drove you to the airport last
week oh my God uh Lloyd right wow
you have my briefcase up I have it at my
hotel room you want to jump on the bike
with me we can go get it
just wait right here okay okay flush you
bastard
bastard oh no no you needed that no
please God no no
oh
I guess this would have to be the
crescendo of a movie like this
this movie's a workout it's like a
cringe workout
reach you to the top
no
just there I wish I could have run up
those stairs you're the woman I've been
waiting for my whole life I've never
felt this way about anybody
desperately wants to make sweet sweet
love to you
[Music]
oh
I like you Mary oh hell I like you a lot
I like you a lot what are my chances not
good one out of a hundred more like one
out of a million
so you're telling me there's a chance
of course
an indomitable spirit
hurry I have some news about your
husband what was all that one in a
million talk aren't you gonna invite me
in oh look out now hey harry you never
called oh oh you didn't give him your
number
excuse me Carmen excuse me I'm the
rightful owner of that briefcase that
you've been carrying around you open it
up open it up
what is this ugh ugh ugh that's as good
as money sir those are ious
look we gotta have serious talk I got a
confession I'm all good
no how do you guys know each other we
used to be best friends yeah until he
turned into a backstabber me a
backstabber no you can work this out I
was the one that got you into this whole
mess come on shoot me wait no no do me
first I stole your girl Lloyd I deserve
it ouch no Mary and I went skiing we
made a snowman she touched my leg okay
kill him kill him
I will not be fooled by this I will not
be four minutes you killed my best
friend you bastard you're about to be
reunited
[Music]
you're a horrible shot yep
[ __ ] me
hey special officer Beth Jordan hey nice
very nice well done Harry she grabbed me
down the lobby explained what was up
then they slapped this bulletproof vest
on me and gave me a gun
[Laughter]
definitely worth the trip she's so rangy
here I'm glad we were able to help her
out you did a good deed either way a
roundabout eventually kind of honey
there's someone I want to introduce you
to he's the kindest gentlest man I've
ever met will you meet him no much
oh no oh what what
wow huh of course my husband Bobby
hi Bobby hi I'm so happy for you
it's a nice little subversion there
first Mary dumps US then the cops take
our Nest Egg then our hog breaks down
yeah when are we ever gonna catch a
break
[Laughter]
[Music]
up hi guys we're going on a national
bikini tour of course and we're looking
for two oil boys who can grease us up
before each competition two oil boys the
the destiny calls you are in luck
there's a town about three miles that
way I'm sure you'll find a couple guys
there okay thanks dumb Dumb and Dumber
Dumb and Dumber do you realize what
you've done
yes come on come on you'll have to
excuse my friend he's a little slow the
town is back that way of course damn it
two lucky guys are gonna be driving
around with those girls for the next
couple months don't worry we'll catch
our break too
just gotta keep our eyes open keep those
eyes open
Lauren Holly that's her name yes
and Mike Starr
I think my dad worked with Lauren Holly
back in the day
God
very fun very fun very wacky movie
I was again I was very curious as to how
this would hold up and and how I would
yeah
oh goodness
yeah like you know uh
I know kind of the I came in knowing
sort of what the vibe was to expect and
it was the sort of thing where I was
like okay you know like this is gonna be
juvenile certainly to some extent it's
gonna be a bit base
um but you know I have a soft see you
know as much as uh as much as I didn't
grow up with the the Adam Sandler or the
Jim Carrey School of Comedy I do have
and intense appreciation for the silly
and absurd and things that are like
committedly gleefully stupid like so you
know when people take stupid stuff
really seriously that's that's quite
funny to me and uh I think this
certainly has that quality like it has a
certain aspect of
of like knowing stupid like you know
it's Dumb and Dumber is the perfect
title they are both dumb in their own
ways this is they yin yang each other in
certain you know complementary patterns
where you know it's like uh Harry can
read at least you know uh Lloyd is a
little more cunning in his dealings with
people but they're both idiots in their
own unique ways and a lot of the time
like I said it kind of reminded me of a
comic strip like it does because you
know there is something I mean it is
like a sketch comedy in its construction
as a movie you know like a lot of the
major plot you're not really spending
that much time on this whole Ransom
thing like it's there it's part of the
story but you know really the point is
to get Harry and Lloyd on the road and
to get them into all sorts of different
wacky you know scenarios and whatnot and
see how they will respond to all those
different things and what you know uh
prompts we can give Jim Carrey and Jeff
Daniels to run away with and play with
and uh and yeah you know
as much as uh uh you know like that
certainly is motivated by the the film
style of being a sort of situation
comedy there is something more you know
directly in the writing of these little
jokes and sketches like I see why the
Fairly Brothers eventually did a Three
Stooges movie
um because they are stooges like it's
like having Larry and Curly together and
all they need is a mo and for a brief
moment there uh for a brief moment there
with uh uh the Hitman I'm gonna have to
learn that actor's name because uh yeah
he's in he's in my favorite movies and
Ed Wood but he's also in uh a bunch of
things you know I feel like there are a
lot of character actors throughout this
especially from the comedy circuit and
then probably if you've seen other
fairly Bros movies but yeah there's
something like innately sort of Comedy
cereal or comic strip about this uh and
I think that's part of the key to the
charmingness of the stupidity and to the
occasional cleverness they're in because
you data there are a couple different
modes this exists in sometimes this is
going you know for completely stupid and
like how much more stupid could it get
and that's where it you know kind of
comes in and surprises you or it gives
you sort of exactly what you were
imagining but then it one-ups it in some
kind of other terrible way like with the
laxative and like oh the toilet's broken
you're gonna have to literally like dump
the toilet out the window and that was
the moment I thought was going to turn
into you know perhaps more than you
expected it to
um but I don't know like this is
I see what's classic about this most
certainly and I really really enjoyed it
again like I felt like this could be a
movie that I could easily read the
parachute press book sorry depending on
which version of this you're watching
the credits are still rolling as I'm
rambling off here uh and now I'm very
fascinated to see what the novelization
of Dumb and Dumber looks like and reads
like
um but yeah like this has that innately
Charming Stooges kind of vibe to it and
uh and yeah it's sort of multiplied by a
comic strip sense of Quirk and humor and
yeah like this seemed like a movie that
I could easily walk into and be like
yeah you know I was amused but I I see
you know uh something that you would
have to be there at the time to love or
or like ah you know this is aged to a
degree where I'm not at the right you
know age or point in my life to find
this like truly hilarious or whatever
but I thought this was pretty hilarious
like there are certain jokes and moments
that haven't aged amazingly you know
there's certainly a lot of gay jokes and
stuff like that that aren't super
inspired but also aren't you know any
more hateful than you know your kind of
garden variety like thrown out there
like ah it's part of the situation
they're gonna be like oh you know you're
gonna run into a guy in a truck stop
like you know they're still funny things
around those jokes and they're still
funny aspects to those jokes even if
they haven't entirely aged great but for
the most part like I thought this this
was able to sing because everybody
around them for the most part is it
understands the assignment is taking the
roles seriously enough and then you have
uh Jim Carrey and Jeff Daniels who again
anger the whole thing with the right
blend of sincerity and stupidity like
they are
clearly and completely committed to
these two characters to Harry Dunn and
Lloyd Christmas and this you know wacky
relationship they've had over time and
uh and we didn't even get a resolve on
that whole thing with uh with Harry's
ex-girlfriend
um but even that like I appreciated that
while this isn't the most like you know
uh like it's a madcap road story in a
lot of ways you know it's a road trip
movie
um but the plotting is pretty simple
obviously you know she leaves the
briefcase Lloyd's in love with Mary uh
Swanson and so they they travel the
country when they hit rock bottom when
they have you know they get tangled up
in this uh Ransom uh situation so for
two different scenarios you know they're
traveling across the country and
eventually yeah like the The Ransom
stuff does Factor back in but like most
of the story you're basically watching
them get into different hijinks and
you're watching their friendship be
tested and uh yeah so to get to the end
and to have it be that
they spend all the money which is just
fun and just makes for you know again a
bunch of goofy hijinks and sight gags
and whatnot but having it be that yeah
she is married like they they give you
certain elements in in clever uh
cleverly timed ways like having it be
that she just leaves the briefcase and
for a moment you just think it's because
she just was distracted by Lloyd you
know the in the crash outside uh and
then moments later like a couple scenes
or shots later like they let you live in
Lloyd's perspective for that moment
being like Oh my gosh she noticed me she
was you know must be uh you know oh no
right I distract her she left the
briefcase you know like it's a it's a
romantic moment for him and it's a sweet
moment and then yeah it turns into just
the reason for him to travel and find
her and fixate on her uh beyond their
initial interaction uh but then yeah
like a couple scenes later you learn
like oh [ __ ] that's Ransom money and
there are also these two you know goons
who are you know trying to go collect it
and who are now you know chasing them
across the country and uh yeah yeah like
I appreciated that by the end you know
they do pay off the ransom the the not
the husband but the guy
um you know who's who her family who
they've led into her family who's
working with them who is you know
secretly behind all this like they don't
really go to any you see him and you
know what his deal is you know who he is
supposed to be in this movie what role
he's going to play pretty much and they
don't do a whole lot to you know make
that side of the story particularly uh
you know they don't do a lot there to
misguide you or throw a red herring into
the mix or make you doubt that that's
the case like pretty much from the time
you see that guy you're like oh yeah
this guy's gonna be the bad guy he's
gonna be the main bad guy
um but I do I always get a kick out of
the story where it's like characters are
so stupid that people think they're
brilliant just because they can't
predict or comprehend what strange uh
you know breadcrumbs they're leaving in
their wake when really they're just
bumbling around and you know kind of
wreaking havoc on everything and yeah I
mean that's a lot of what happens here
but I like too that like the the story
fixating on Mary Merry Christmas which
is a great like a way Homer of a joke
for me uh yeah like them fixating on her
and then Harry going out on this date
and having them mix up with her stepmom
and who's supposed to meet Lloyd at the
bar and everything and even setting up
uh the girl who turns out to be the FBI
agent like they have you guessing and
looking at other things and that's kind
of what makes up for some of the you
know the more Bare Bones parts of the
story that are clearly you know this is
one of those movies where certain things
you can tell are here just to
orchestrate circumstances or just to get
us to the next set piece or a bit of
wacky hijinks or whatever
um but yeah having it be that ultimately
she doesn't choose either of them and
this fixation is deluded you know kind
of pulls you to a New Perspective beyond
the movie you know it kind of gives you
this uh peripheral sense of both humor
and magic in that yeah like they both
aren't the right one for this girl
they've been you know objectifying and
and you know placing her on this
pedestal both of them in different ways
and you know following this crazy
journey and anybody who's looking at
this logically would be like if that guy
showed up he would be probably pretty
creeped out I mean even at one point in
the movie he says it like I can't just
go up to her be like I followed you
across the country that'd be super
creepy and like so much of what they do
is super creepy anyway
um but you know the movie maintains its
charm by placing them into this bubble
that they exist in and into this way
we're like yeah I mean they do cause a
fair amount of people some Misfortune
and there are aspects they sell that
blind kid the dead bird and everything
like you know they they aren't the most
benevolent characters of all time you
know and they can certainly be very
Petty but they do seem to yeah exist in
this bubble sort of beyond all reason
and beyond all intellect and uh yeah
it's the charm of the movie and again
like everybody I thought did a really
nice job just kind of bouncing off of
them and giving them different straight
men to play off of and uh yeah like I
appreciated the different little uh
comedian uh you know characters who
popped up and whatnot I'm trying to uh
find the guy who played uh the the you
know the the big heavy the the the the
Hitman dude who they were like hanging
out with for that brief moment of time
uh because that guy you know that guy be
holding it down in the character active
Department every one of these movies I
love to play the game of like that guy
like there's always a bunch of you know
different that guys that you see that uh
you know populate these different movies
but that guy's a great character actor
and I liked the two of them together uh
him and the the woman who was there the
other the two of them you know Hitman
characters whatever their names were
um yeah man and and of course the
running with sea bass and all their
different like hats this is also a movie
where like I would love to go back
through it and pick out the different
um you know like site gags and stuff
like that and and little uh like anytime
anybody's like reading something or
whatever uh there has to be a certain
level of uh you just you know set
dressing involved that you know is
probably like you know they do this
silly uh credits at the beginning with
all the misspelled uh uh you know title
cards and stuff like that and I think
when they get to the airport or
something like someone's reading a book
called like of course you're angry or
whatever uh about uh you know family uh
you know uh dispute management and
whatnot like yeah this is one of those
movies where I'm sure the more you watch
it the more like stupid jokes will click
in your head and the more uh yeah just
like little gags and things or little uh
you know set deck uh you know nerdy
flourishes will jump out at you but yeah
just as an experience as a blaster in
the past uh this is the kind of silly
character comedy that does tickle me and
yeah like I'm used to like I've seen
probably more straight man Jeff Daniels
than uh you know comedian Jeff Daniels
but I thought he was really good in this
too I mean like obviously you know Jim
Carrey you come into this and he's doing
you know what you would kind of expect
of Jim Carrey he's doing you know the
classic Jim Carrey like when I even
though I'd never seen this you know this
is a Jim Carrey character through and
through it's somebody that uh yeah you
would automatically kind of go to as a
quintessential example of his you know
personality on screen but I really like
Jeff Daniels you know completely meeting
him halfway and uh yeah he just you know
giving this truly Earnest uh sense of
stupidity so that when they have those
brief moments you know you could tell
they're not judging the characters and
yeah and those brief moments of uh uh
sincerity where you know Lloyd is
professing his love for Mary and and you
know being afraid he'll never feel a
connection like this again you know he's
sort of tearing up like those moments
they gotta go go to a place you know
that has those emotions in it and and
yeah like it's it's impressive when you
know those moments happen with the both
of them
um but you know I appreciated where that
that aspect of the spectrum too where
you have an actor like Jim Carrey who is
more through and through associated with
comedy and from at least my perspective
coming in Jeff Daniels then having more
of the dramatic but also I know he can
do comedy and Broad comedy at that and
so yeah having him uh on the other end
of the spectrum you know playing very
silly but also again lending his own
sort of nuances as uh you know a
dramatic actor too just yeah it it
nailed everything I thought Lauren Holly
uh again like the just the amount out of
like reacting like this is a movie where
you have to hire a bunch of people to
react basically uh like a half of what
you're going to be doing if you're not
the two leads is reacting to what they
are doing and what kind of craziness
they are giving you and like there's so
many quotables there's so many iconic
moments like to try and touch on every
bit of the story and every bit of you
know comedic uh uh chicanery you know it
would be you know you'd just be like
checking off the entire movie at that
point but uh yeah it was nice to go back
to Colorado through this lens to go back
to the Stanley Hotel which apparently
Jim Carrey like refused to stay out
after this I think uh so there's a fun
fact for you I think it was after this
or during this one of the two
um and yeah a Mike star there you go
Mike Starr and Karen Duffy I like them a
lot together as the two uh you know sort
of goons uh in pursuit of Harry and
Lloyd throughout the movie and just yeah
like they're I thought the the the the
way that they made the plot not too
important helped them them to do things
that were a little bit more interesting
with it ironically if that makes sense
just you know when the plot actually
kicks back in there are moments where
you're like oh cool because we're not so
bound to this being the bones of the
movie the structure of the movie this is
really more just auxiliary for what
we're here to do this is just to add the
occasional Stakes
um yeah I thought that that made for
nice involvement from characters like
that so yeah you briefly have Mike Starr
along the journey with them and then uh
and then yeah like Karen Duffy pops back
up later and just I don't know it lends
a little bit of credence to this
criminal organization that you don't
spend very much time with throughout the
movie and uh and and and and shouts out
uh that that dream sequence uh I know
Greg has referenced this to me before
and he maybe even showed me a brief
portion of it but that dream sequence he
has the wheel is is is so funny is when
he's fallen asleep and he's dreaming
about like rescuing her and then like
you know taking on everybody in the
restaurant who also so wants to you know
canoodle with and and encroach upon
their uh you know canoodle with her and
encroach upon their love you know you
got this like waiter just like kissing
all up and down her arm like it's so
wacky and so silly and the you know the
fight scene portion of it is so goofy
and and just the things that he thinks
are cool like this is one of those
movies where the stupidity works because
of how well it knows the perspective of
its characters and how well it locks you
into those and so yeah like I feel like
I could ramble on for days about this
but it doesn't really need it because
yeah like was it funny it was pretty
funny and you know good again use of
physical and character comedy but also
prop comedy again like that goes in with
those things but is its own art form and
I thought Jim Carrey especially had a
lot of great little prop based moments a
lot of great interact like you know kind
of like the way Jackie Chan in a fight
scene interacts with an object you know
so does Lloyd Christmas in this movie
um so yeah man a good uh good Blast from
the Past I'm glad I checked this out off
my list I will certainly watch it again
at some point and I get why people love
it and uh and I got some uh my heart is
warm I got a little bit of love for it
too out of this experience so hey leave
me your thoughts anything you want to
point out about the movie any trivia
anything at all just leave it for me to
find and go oh interesting a little hard
on that comment uh much love to you guys
for now and uh hey let's let's shout out
some bullets let's do a patreon
Gabriel Gabrielle how is it going buddy
I just wanted to shout you out today you
leave so much opportunity here it's just
your first name you could be anybody you
could be it could be your last name you
could be Peter Gabriel for all I know
but hey appreciate you being here you're
one of our more recent patrons and hey I
know we've been shouting now people
who've like been here forever but it
means the world when anybody joins up
and especially I mean you know there are
people who stick on stick around for a
long time and that's cool but sometimes
you know they gotta leave us and they
gotta leave room for people like you and
I'm glad that you decided to hop on and
to keep on with us no matter how long
you do I hope you're having a good
holiday season I hope you're enjoying
the stuff that we have here I hope you
are a fan of this movie and uh and
didn't have to like I mean you could
just skip to the end but you know I hope
this wasn't an excruciating like oh I
shot me out of this and if that's the
case I will make it up to you because we
are here to please uh but yeah Gabriel I
hope you're doing well I hope you're
you're having a good holiday good uh you
know new year as well depending on when
you're watching this maybe it's already
2023 who knows uh but yeah hope you're
doing well we'll catch you on the next
one much love and uh cheers for now
[Music]